I guess the black shuck was not as
impressed with Bob's clunky guitar
playing as Mar Ellen was and decided to
attack him should have gone with Baja
man Bob at first I thought it was kind
of unfair that Bob is essentially being
hunted because of daniela's
transgression but considering that there
are already several other demons
terrorizing Daniela it would make sense
that the shuck would try to go after Bob
many of the characters involved in the
initial lycanthropy stories that I
discussed in mythology such as Gilgamesh
and Lon were tested to see if they could
hold back their Primal instincts with
the werewolf transformation serving as
an indicator if they failed to do so in
this case Bob's primal instinct is
trying to get with Mari Ellen but
there's a clear boundary that has been
set the Warren don't want marellen
having boys over on a subtextual level
the black Shu represents a test of Bob's
restraints to reveal what kind of person
he actually is he seems respectful when
he's told that he can't come in but
ultimately tries to find kind of a
loophole by Serena her from outside I
personally think this is fine because
it's not like Mary Ellen is going to get
in trouble for having an admirer who she
didn't let in but either way this
midnight mut is going to put the Bob's
got balls nickname to the tag